this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the shiki
science show where in this video we're
going to talk about cellular senescence
and a recent study that's been published
in cell metabolism
that has identified so called oxylipins
that are involved in the development of
cellular senescence
but more intriguingly are for the
potential for the detection of xenolysis
which is the destruction of senescent
cells
so in this video i'll begin by giving an
overview of what senescent cells are
and ways in which senescent cells can be
identified we'll then take a look at
some of the data in this paper
and some of the ulci lipones that
they've discovered to be involved in the
senescence process
will then evaluate how this information
could have potential therapeutic value
so first then what is cellular
senescence
well cellular senescence can be thought
of as a cell phase
whereby cells stop dividing and enter a
permanent arrest of cell proliferation
and are characterized by many phenotypic
changes
including cellular hypertrophy nuclear
and epigenetic rearrangements
and metabolic alterations moreover they
develop the so-called
senescence-associated secretory
phenotype
and this describes how senescent cells
start secreting a variety of different
biologically active molecules
and these include a variety of different
inflammatory factors
and growth factors that can impact the
surrounding environments of the
senescent cells
and so we currently think that senescent
cells have this so-called sasp
to help mediate the pathophysiological
effects
and so what that describes is the fact
that these inflammatory factors
help to reinforce and spread senescence
to surrounding cells
moreover it can be used to activate the
immune responses to help clear the
senescent cells and get rid of them
and whilst this has been shown to be
useful in wound healing and development
impairments in the clearance of
senescent cells can result in chronic
inflammation which could have
deleterious pro-aging effects
and indeed it's been seen in both mice
and in human tissue
that senescent cells accumulate with age
and so
if senescent cells can drive chronic
inflammation and have deleterious
pro-aging effects
it was hypothesized that clearing
senescent cells in a process known as
stenolysis
using so-called psenolytics which kills
senescent cells
may have benefits for reducing chronic
inflammation and help to reduce the
aging process
and so this has already been tested in a
variety of different studies
in a variety of different ways this 2018
study
used a combination of the satinib and
quercetin
which together act as analytics and gave
them
intermittently to aged mice and showed
that it alleviated physical dysfunction
and increased post-treatment survival by
36
while reducing mortality hazard to 65
in a different study they used a genetic
approach to clear senescent cells
expressing p16 which is an important
gene in mediating the cell cycle arrest
and what they found is that in mice that
had the clearance of p16 expressing
cells
compared to the control mice it extended
the median lifespan in both male and
female mice
suggesting that the presence of
senescent cells is shortening healthy
lifespan
however the efficacy of removing
senescent cells for therapeutic use
has had some setbacks in terms of being
able to translate this idea to human use
most notably being the early clinical
failure
seen in unity by technologies ubxo101
for the treatment of osteoarthritis
and so part of the reason for this is
that our understanding of senescent
cells is ever expanding
and secondly because detecting senescent
cells
and more and from that detecting their
clearance currently is quite a
challenging thing to do
that doesn't involve very invasive
procedures
and one of the areas that is still under
great investigation
is of the senescence-associated
phenotype
which at the moment has primarily been
studied by looking at the proteins that
are secreted
mainly because this is a relatively easy
thing to analyze
in comparison other molecules that are
secreted by
senescent cells such as different lipids
have been under investigated
and so this nicely segues back to this
latest cell metabolism paper
whereby they have identified that
oxylipin biosynthesis
seems to be reinforcing the development
of cellulosin essence
including the sasp and allows detection
of sonolysis
so being able to detect when a senescent
cell has been killed
and this work has come out from the bach
institute
so the first thing they did in this
study is look at what lipids accumulate
inside cells that have become senescent
and what they found is that certain
subsets of lipids
significantly increased or decreased
upon selections
notably the most highly elevated
senescence associated lipid
was a prostaglandin known as 181b
dihomo15 deoxy prostaglandin
j2 you'll be glad to know that we can
somewhat simplify that
to dihomeo 15d pgj2
although it's still a bit of a mouthful
anyway
prostaglandins are a subset of oxy
lipins
which are a really interesting group of
lipids that are derived from the
oxidation
of polyunsaturated fatty acids
most notably the 20 and 22 carbon fatty
acids such as arachidonic acids
and adrenic acids with dihomo15d
pg jt deriving from an adrenic acid
and so these dihomea prostaglandins have
been less well investigated
than the prostaglandins that derive from
arachidonic acids
the most famous which is probably
prostaglandin e2
and so these oxy lipids have a variety
of physiological effects
that range from inflammation fever
vasoconstriction
pain hair loss asthma and fibrosis
and so maybe unsurprisingly the enzyme
that can convert
arachidonic acid into these different
oxylipins
such as prostaglandins can be inhibited
by aspirin which is a pretty well-known
painkiller and one of the genes that
encodes the protein that gets inhibited
by aspirin
known as cox-2 standing for
cyclooxygenase 2
was actually shown in another recent
study to be
involved in the senescence process
whereby cooks ii was observed to be
upregulated into essence and control the
expression of multiple sasp components
and this activity was important for
mediating so-called senescence
surveillance
whereby the immune cells can get
recruited in to clear the senescent
cells
in this paper described in liver tissue
anyway to go back to this
cell metabolism paper so far we've seen
that senescent cells
accumulate highly this dihomo15d
pgj2 and this was also confirmed in fivo
so in mice whereby they saw increased up
regulation
of genes involved in oxylipin synthesis
in mice treated with doxorubicin to
induce
the development of senescent cells in
these mice
and when they cleared the senescent
cells in this mice you can see that the
expression level of these different
genes also goes back down
and what they nicely show in this study
is that this accumulation
of dihomo15d pgj2
i think i'm getting quite good at this
now isn't just
a bystander accumulating internet cells
but it actually seems to be able to
reinforce the development of cellulosin
essence
and they show that this seems to be
happening due to the fact that dihomo15d
pgj2 seems to be able to increase the
activity
of the protein ras which is interesting
given that
constitutive high up regulational fast
alone can induce
the development of senescence so-called
oncogene induced senescence
and increased rust activity also
increases the activity of
p53 a protein that i'm very fond of
that to complete the circle also
increases the synthesis of cox2 and
ptgds
which are both involved in prostaglandin
synthesis and so you end up in this full
circle whereby
daihomu 15d pgj2 increases grass
activity
which then can reinforce its own
production by downstream increasing the
activity of the enzymes that
enable its generation and the
interesting thing about this circuit
is that it's so-called cell autonomous
it happens within one cell
whereby the dihomo 15d pgj2
is acting on the rest that's in the same
cell that it's in
basically what i'm trying to say is that
the daihomo15d
pgj2 seems to be staying within the
senescent cell
and this is in contrast to most
prostaglandins that are typically
thought to be secreted by the cell
and so given this finding the authors
hypothesized
that cenolisis the death of senescent
cells
might be releasing this daihomo15d pgj2
and well their hypothesis was correct
this is seen clearly
in this figure here whereby they took
conditioned media
from senescent cells growing in culture
and analyzed the abundance of daihomo15d
pgj2 and so by taking this conditions
media
instead of the cells they can analyze
what's being secreted by the cells
so when you've got senescent cells just
treated with dmso
which in theory shouldn't have any
impact on the senescent cells
you can see that the abundance of
dihomo15dpgj2
is pretty low however when the senescent
cells were treated with
abt263 which is a well-known
cenolitic there is a great increase in
the abundance
of dioma 15d pgj2
suggesting that this prostaglandin could
be used as a biomarker for cenolysis
and this is further supported within
fivo data from mice
whereby they also cleared the senescent
cells with the same cenolitic
abt 263 and they found that mice that
had senescent cells and treated with the
synolitic compound
showed increases in their plasma and
urine
of dihomo daihomo15d pgj2
and so this has caused a lot of interest
given that urine and plasma
are much less invasive than other
approaches to be able to detect the
presence of senescent cells
moreover it offers the potential to be
able to identify
and evaluate the efficacy of different
synolytics
to see if they are actually removing the
senescent cells as
is thought and this is particularly
welcome news
given the fact that many analytics are
now in the early stages
of different clinical trials for a
variety of different
age-associated diseases so what would be
interesting would be to see if there are
other markers now
that can be used to detect synolysis in
addition to this dihomea 15d pgj2
had to say it one more time and also to
see if this biomarker could be used for
different types of senescent cells
as senescent cells aren't all the same
they arise in different contexts
in different tissues induced by
different ways
and so it would be important to
investigate further if this
prostaglandin
accumulates broadly in senescent cells
and whether it could always be effective
and so all in all this study further
helps us to understand
the role of lipids in the development of
cellular senescence
and also highlights how this
prostaglandin i'll say it one more time
dihomey 15d pgj2
accumulates in senescent cells but gets
secreted
on cenolysis which could therefore be
used as a biomarker to evaluate the
efficacy of different synalytics
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video
longevity technology for which i'm very
grateful
longevity technology deliver high
quality daily news and
insights on research investments and
technologies
that extend healthspan and lifespan find
the link to their website
in the description so i hope you've
learned something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening